u.s lawmakers have known since the 1960s
that burning fossil fuels pumping co2
into the atmosphere is a recipe for a
hotter planet and possible cataclysmic
climate change they
like many around the world have spent
decades denying the science or simply
ignoring it
well look around the world now droughts
flooding wildfires melting glaciers
rising sea levels record breaking heat
waves ignoring is no longer an option
the u.s congress is now on the verge of
passing its most significant legislation
in history aimed at combating climate
change the u.s senate gave its approval
by a 51 to 50 margin with democratic
vice president kamala harris casting the
time breaking vote not a single
republican senator voted for the plan
which in addition to offering tax
incentives for reducing carbon emissions
also aims to slash the cost of
prescription drugs
the u.s house is expected to approve the
legislation next week
here is the senate majority leader chuck
schumer
as you know it's been a long tough and
winding road
at last we've arrived and we are elated
every member of my caucus is elated
about what happened because we've really
we've changed the world
in a way that you rarely get an
opportunity to do that
our bill reduces inflation
lowers costs
creates millions of manufacturing jobs
enhances our energy security and is the
boldest climate package in u.s history
the senate has now passed the most
significant bill to fight the climate
crisis ever
some big claims there from chuck schumer
let's go to washington dc now talk with
our
washington bureau chief enos pull good
to see you enos
let's help our viewers understand
something here
how did efforts to reduce prescription
drug prices and efforts to slow climate
change how did they end up in the same
legislation
this piece of legislation brand known as
the
inflation reduction act has been in the
works for over a year now but the
democrats were able to muscle it through
this weekend after really endless
roadblocks so it might be indeed seem to
be an interesting mix of topics from
fighting the climate change to reduce
drug prices the reason for that is the
simple fact
that the biden administration had to
agree on many many compromises to get
the necessary votes from within its own
party
and we've got chuck schumer as we just
heard there saying that this is the
boldest climate package in history
saying that we've changed the world but
i decided to crunch the numbers here the
part of the legislation aimed at
fighting climate change is funded by an
amount that is not even
five percent of the annual u.s defense
budget so is congress throwing peanuts
at climate change
well i understand that it is kind of
appealing to compare these two figures
as one could say actually fighting the
climate climate catastrophe is also a
huge battlefield but brent i think we
have to be fair here
the original buildback batter plan was a
little over a trillion dollars but it
was never going to happen with this
congress and how politicized the
political institutions are these days
here in the united states so
yes for the first time is making real
investments in combating climate change
and
i think at least this is the beginning
yeah in this environment you make a very
good point you know we should be glad
that we're getting as much as we are
getting considering how the politics are
right now on capitol hill today china
said that it will no longer cooperate
with the us on fighting climate change
now this is important because the u.s
and china they're the world's number one
number two emitters of greenhouse gases
i'm wondering how much do you think this
is just
beijing blustery
well the white house has been in a tough
position with international challenges
like china some speculate actually that
this is potentially the country puffing
chest after house speaker nancy pelosi
took the controversial trip to taiwan
so politically there is a lot of
bipartisanship between the democrats and
the republicans here in the u.s in how
it views taiwan and china but
indeed when it comes to fighting the
climate catastrophe
it will be much much harder if not
impossible without the cooperation
between china and the us and
this legislation despite its
shortcomings the compromise despite
china's possible hyperbole i mean it
remains a major political victory for
president biden does
well the white house and senate
democrats have been going back and forth
on this major piece of
legislation as we just uh talked about
so democrats who are struggling to keep
their majority in both houses in the
upcoming midterm election can
effectively go to voters with really
tangible progress despite an extremely
divided congress but
with the election only months away brent
it may be a little bit too late as many
many voters have become said in their
political view
all right twc news poll with the latest
tonight from washington enis as always
thank you